you need to watch this if you want to
revolutionize your farm combined
Harvesters are here to transform
agriculture imagine this one machine
that can cut thresh and clean your crops
in a single pass that's the power of the
combine harvester these mechanical
marbles are equipped with advanced
technology like GPS for precision
farming and sensors to monitor crop
Health in real time but it doesn't stop
there combined Harvesters reduce labor
costs save time and increase yields
they're environmentally friendly too
minimizing waste and maximizing
efficiency from we to soybeans these
Giants handle at all no more endless
hours in the field with a combine
harvester you're farming smarter not
harder so are you ready to join the
future of farming combined Harvesters
are here and they're changing
agriculture forever hit that like button
if you're excited about the future of
farming subscribe to the channel and
watch full video in the link below